this is his
third fourth time speaking at this
conference spoken a lot of them I think
he missed one year I don't know why
we'll get to the bottom of that later
why he missed one year but he hasn't
taken a vacation in three years
and well he hasn't taken more than a one
day vacation three years and his first
vacation in three years starts tomorrow
she's gonna yeah but he's gonna miss
half the conference tomorrow but good
for him right good for him all right
let's give him Applause for that yeah
yeah
but he promised he'll watch it virtually
from from the road
so everyone please welcome Rafi uh good
morning everybody my name is a Rafi love
I am a lead data scientist with
deloitte's uh GPS Federal uh we do doing
a little bit also state and local and a
commercial but mostly focusing on a
advanced analytics in
um
in the federal space crossing over all
agencies and
um essentially the store what I'm going
to talk about this tomorrow this morning
um you're not going to learn anything
new this is this is really about how to
take how we took essentially something
that all of you know a little bit of
clustering a little bit of modeling a
little bit of a markdown and really put
it together to create a utility this is
actually not something that sits on your
laptop not something that a a only you
know or end up in a PowerPoint for a
decision nothing wrong with the decision
but how do you actually impact the
process how do you impact an entire
agency how do you impact the lives of
1600 families using tools that you
already know that you already have in
your positions and and you know doing it
with a with tools that you you you you
know already
so
um let's start by
um really talking about ah
stop moving all right let's start a
little bit a little bit of a kind of
like sending the stage so what are we
trying to do
um again this I'm I'm not representing
the agency over here this is really talk
about R uh but in a few words what you
are said is trying to do is to utilize
capabilities utilize data to make
informed decision on where there is a
demand for their Foreign Service
officers for their individual around the
world not as necessarily as a response
to a crisis so that's like you know
Ukraine for example not as that but as a
general course of business
um as a where they're distributed all
around the world how do I know what kind
of like the offer a peace officers do I
need health officers and where
um can I really use a capability with
with the data and then align them to the
right place
um couple of terminologies that I want
to I want to make sure that that we're
aware over here so emission is a
location
um there is also Regional which is
essentially an area so a mission is
let's say Laos
um a backstop is a particular function
within the mission or a particular
function of a think about this a job
series you can see this on the right
over here engineering environment
education democracy
um and finally the the point over here
is that we have a lot of different
mechanisms fso fscs I'm going to use
that but essentially it's Foreign
Service officers the other mechanism of
hiring for position uh CS Civil Service
somebody who's permanent over there
um and there is temporary as well what's
interesting about this and you can see
this at the table on the bottom right is
that we are talking over here about
numbers that are being controlled by
Congress so it's not like they can go
and hire whatever they want is
essentially there is also a limit so I
can come and calculate that I need 10
000 people it doesn't matter because
Congress only allowed us to do
um 16 for example actual 2019 was 1675.
and and by the way you can see this
number in 1980 over here this was a
direct result of the work that you're
about to see in a second the fact that
we went up so again your R tools are
valuable it's about utility it's not
just about it's cool
um so what what do we do we did this
now I don't expect this is kind of like
the the process that's that's not not
the point but the point is that every
item over here was controlled by r
so let's start speaking for a couple
minutes around the data so what do we
have over here in order to support our
data we have anywhere from head count
information and by the way the numbers
that you see over here the the
visualization those are not real numbers
um you know that's not that's not the
point and you know not real
titles I changed some of most of them
um but that's how the tables looks like
so we have information about people we
had information about grades we have
information if the supervisors are not
supervised we have information
historically where they were so I know
who was where at what position and
theoretically what they touched and how
much of money and we'll talk about money
in a second they touch and what kind of
information did they know I know
historical right so we spent a hundred
million dollars on Democracy in
Afghanistan I also know
um information around the the the with
the future like what do I want to
accomplish because essentially we want
to do for this is all forward-looking
what do we want to do next year so we
have information so think about tables
and PDFs right extracting those not
crazy sophisticated this is not deep
learning but
um not the Deep learning is
sophisticated it's really just
regression but whatever
um
um we we essentially have the oldest all
this information a kind of uh to collect
as well as we have uh specific
information about local we'll touch on
the dotical in a second that's probably
one of the coolest most impacted things
that we've done over there essentially
how do I collect something that is local
what happened on the ground
so
um let's talk for a few minutes about
model approach and how that's impact the
the the capability and and all of this
again give me another minute and then
we'll get to the r stuff so we're
starting with the different concept I
want you to understand the concept of
um you know we have historical
information right I want to do a
prediction I need historical information
I know I know how much when where who
right I have also the level of effort by
implementing partner so that's the data
quote it's all local a dollar in
in Afghanistan is not the same as Dollar
in
Greenland it's also if I write a check
it's a lot easier then I have to manage
that
you know Dollar by Dollar so how do I
make sure that I account for the fact
that there's it matters the the level of
effort matters
um how do I translate that all to
something I can predict so that's really
the key over here measurement of work
it's unitless you new unit that we
developed for usaid it's unitless unit
um and it's essentially measure that you
know you need 400 measurement of work
for a particular location and then any
sort of adjustment that we might need it
looks like this and this is where we're
going to start getting into how do you
drive utility from your art capability
we're really starting from the best base
model which we have the mow this is
where I can kind of take all the
information and kind of predict that
we get to the next level which is I know
what's I kind of starting to think about
everything is local what's the
information that I know about the local
how many PhD in economics I have in a
particular country that I can use to
help me in economics versus I have no
one and I need to bring them from the
United States or I need to Outsource
that to somebody who doesn't know much
um I'm following up so mow those dots
model will get to the extra boost in a
second and others the base with
adjustments that's the data call
markdown that is a survey that is a
analysis of network
the a global strategy for example a
development priority climate deia as
well as some sort of limitation uh
there's certain rules that we have to
adjust for and then any sort of mission
level calculation and by mission level
calculation is like
our president shows up in a particular
Mission you know this preparation this
work that needs to be done that does not
account in anything that's just like you
know on top of that's on top of
everything but from a measurement of
work we need to account for that so that
is where we start making taking all the
information in the process that you saw
a second ago that you don't have to
remember that's where you actually make
those adjustments and finally okay let's
say that we predicted that you need 5
000 people how do I go back and say I
only have 16.50 I only have 1850 right
as we saw in the first slide what how do
I go about that that's when we design
and this is a essentially it's it's kind
of long but again within your capability
this is where you have an if else
statement a looping and essentially we
are accounting for the marginal benefit
of the next position and you start from
the top and you start going all the way
down
with adjustment so they can make it we
can decide that a particular Mission a
particular area will will be fully
funded for example fully staffed
um so you can adjust for that but again
this is not
super rocket scientist rocket science
but you can actually take
a a and design a waterfall in your
regular r
op it up and we'll talk in a second
about how we wrapped it into kind of
making a decision hey our model says
that you need 10 people but according to
the waterfall only five will be
available considering the fact that we
have limitations from Congress
all right so what does r has to do with
that
we'll start from the model so
essentially what you see over here is
that we essential that's the left side
right we talk about mlw and the design
um this is where we start talking about
actual model so we have a model that was
trained on historical data
um and we kind of generated the last
year and compared to what we actually
have
um and
um each mission was in each backstop was
um was modeled and what's really
interesting over here is as you can see
in the visual this is where we got a lot
of utility this is where we actually
have had the the buy-in on the right
side you see the 45 degree angle
actual versus predicted
um so those this is what we this is the
the this is JiJi plot and this is the
Wall Street Journal
um a type of visualization so the colors
and everything
um but this is ggplot and this is where
we had like the head of HR the head of
the agency is looking at that they're
like okay I get it this is where I have
like actual is a little bit higher and
but this is where and we'll send a
second we'll show in a second how we
actually show the output in the same
kind of manner so visualization matter
um we really have two models
um that and and this is again nothing
over here everybody is sitting over here
probably can do this this is not about a
a something that only we know it's
really about putting the pieces together
so we have a a mixed model over here
that really does the most of the heavy
lifting what we call the base and then
we have the XG boost I really look at
variables that really looks at the the
importance of the different variables
and the different mechanism and really
what we need to account for and the way
that it looks like
is that we really have an aggregation of
the both it's really combined and and
this is where again you need to think
about it's not just about I have a model
I deploy it I'm done it is about how do
you take the different components and
really put them together in a way that
actually makes a difference in a way
that actually produce something that
people can use it's actually valuable
and in this particular case you can see
that this is a particular
um a backstop and the different uh the
different variable importance and then
and the the mixed model that produce
um kind of how many you do I need in
this particular backstop
um I removed the name of the backstop
over here but again the numbers are not
real so that's okay
um and and what comes out of that one is
I need
two backstop officers in Ethiopia for
this particular work for next year so
and that's
how we visualize that and you can see
that again we have the on the left side
over here we have the model prediction
for a particular backstop
um which one is over which one is under
and again this is very easy to explain
45 degree angle everybody understand
this is not
you know AUC and precision and and that
kind of thing I on the right side you
can see we can do the same thing on the
on the emission level
um we also accounting for the clustering
of the different
um funding mechanisms so we want to make
sure that you stay within your cluster
there's a there's a reason why a
particular beer or a particular mission
is doing the way that they do there's
obviously long history of to why so
taking that in into account
none of this again none of this is is a
is is a specifically interested by
itself although the clustering is
actually very interesting because that's
something that
the response that we got is that hey
this is a this is a exactly what
I thought about but I never actually was
able to put it together and this is
where they came in it actually came in
very nicely
fine um the final couple more points one
this isn't it when we started to look at
the positions so how do we communicate
that
one communication is you can see that
the fact that there are positions out
there in a particular Bureau it's
rolling the the mission is changing over
time and you can see for example the
different types of backstop that are in
color coded you can see that some of
them went all it's in and it's from
again left to right
positions rolling all rolling over from
a from a this type of work to this type
of work and a and when you explain that
in that kind of way that it's it's we're
taking into account the fact that old
positions are no longer part of the
picture but the new positions are the
the even though it's the same backstop
and it's the same location with the same
Mission really we need to take that into
account that it's only the the ones at
the end that really matter the ones that
are open from like 20 years ago 30 years
ago that's not what the mission is doing
today
um so visualization matter
and finally you know we spoke about a
quarter over here before
um I am this is still in markdown
um you know we can fight about this
later
um but in in markdown over here what's
really nice about this is that we did
the the global data call all missions
around the world responds to this and
then you can really take the right
information that you need out of this
one you can do the cross tabulation you
actually have a report that our clients
can submit to their leadership we
actually have an understanding as you
can see on the right of what is
important and what is not and in what
level by the mission and then
incorporate that into the model as we
discussed a few slides ago in the in the
process so Mark Dunn was actually a
really key over here in selling this and
essentially that's something that you
can attach to an email and send it
across without individuals having to
learn how to operate the dashboard or
download anything
um so as a communication tool that was
key over here
um one thing that I want to mention over
here for the sake of time is the okay
how do we actually deploy this
um so
the interesting part over here is that
we actually have a platform so how do I
communicate to a with R to a platform
that
um really is based on other technology
in this particular case our solution was
r2py which is essentially a wrapper it's
a python wrapper for r that you can
essentially run underneath and python is
kind of running on tops because this the
platform is in Python so it is it is
essentially not an API based couple my
last talk over here was about how to how
to really utilize API properly and
really this is a this is the future but
in this particular case because
everything is on-prem on platform this
is one solution if you learn anything
from today this is probably it it's
actually very powerful
um that you can run develop all your
work in in R develop all your functions
in our all your model in R and you
actually interact with us through python
because the operation is in Python
final piece over here is and we can't go
without shiny so we then all of that is
then wrapped into a really
um pretty shiny so that we can
communicate that into the to the users
to the to the to the to the the team
that actually need to utilize that and
you can see that you have like the
actual numbers you can have in the
middle of the bottom uh the bottom left
over here you can see the blue and the
green the blue and the red that's
optimal versus actual remember the
waterfall we talked about I can show you
you need 10 but you're only going to get
five
um and then we can also show you kind of
the distribution you can get the data
out through the tables and what's really
nice about it is that you can actually
change parameters and you can actually
change and interact with that and this
is something
um that was new to them which is the
ability to run scenarios that is really
interesting now eventually this shiny
went into an actual
um a a platform that took the shiny and
copied that into a different platform
but without the shiny we'll not be able
to communicate I will use my last 30
second essentially saying going back
four years ago with my first talk this
was from there and this is really the
point again the same point I just
realized at the end when I finished this
uh presentation prep I've realized that
I'm really talking about the same thing
the different scenario which is
essentially the the model is part of a
process
you solve enough little little point
over here and you will get some results
at the end it's not about finding the
most sophisticated model is about
finding utility from what you need
um and really understand
um what is the data that you control
what is the data that you need to
generate and where do you go from there
in order to create a solution to create
a utility for your client
thank you very much